it just has a world rapid championships
in chess and Magnus Carlsen 1 how many
of you know who Magnus Carlsen is a most
and he's been here so you know he can by
see him on the wall somewhere in a
picture he's a world champion and now he
won the world rapid championship but he
had a lot of luck and let's look at this
game from the round before the last
round I think it was I mean I just I
just looked this up so I don't really
know I think it wasn't next to last
round I think there was 15 rounds in the
last round he had some he just looked
like he just needed a draw because he
really just played for a draw and he did
it real efficiently but this this game
he he was white against Grisha who's a
one of the top Russian players and he's
a very good player and unfortunately he
got a winning position with a Carlsen
somehow sneaked out you know he was very
very tricky so I thought it would be
kind of well I mean ok I didn't look at
the games so long but I looked at a
little bit I didn't analyze over the
computer or anything but we'll just see
what happened okay so Carlson was white
it can ok Carlson's white and gray shook
was black so Greece should chose a
King's Indian and I think he plays a
grünfeld usually you got tell me if I'm
talking over people's heads or something
like that I don't know
ok so oops so so this would be 7 and and
Carlsen chose those Amish variation
which is one of the most dangerous ways
to play against the Kings Indian it's
kind of even Bobby Fischer II regarded
this is he always played the Kings
Indian almost not always but usually
that was his main opening against d4 and
this he always referred not always but
he eventually regarded the there's Amish
is the most dangerous or the toughest
system against against King's Indian so
what's the point of this move f3 anyone
got an idea yeah
hmm to hold you for yeah that's one of
them ke4 wasn't threatened but it now
makes that pawn very solid and yeah yeah
it prevents okay that wasn't really a
threat but in some cases if white
brought the knight out to f3
in some cases black could pin it that's
one thing basically White's going any
main thing is okay wants to stop Knight
g4 so he's preparing Bishop III he's
gonna make a setup where he goes Bishop
III Queen to d2 maybe castles Queen side
and creates basic very solid position
yeah similar similar to like a
Yugoslavia tech ants a dragon or the
English attack in an AI Dorf that type
of thing but also white can use business
you can Castle queenside and push the H
pawn up and try to check me like in the
dragon or white can play quiet more
quiet way which is more common and and
just develop your having this solid pawn
structure and generally when black plays
c5 at some point why it's gonna push d5
and gain some space same thing if black
plays 'if I've at some point usually
white pushes d5 and gains of space so
he's trying to so that ended and it's
kind of unclear whether White's gonna go
for the crazy attack or the solid
positional squeeze you never know you
know sometimes the same person could
play it both ways depending on how black
responds but okay here Greece you chose
a system which I've used several times
in fact I had it like a couple weeks ago
as black okay so but actually well he
did it with castling first and then this
it didn't in my game it was like I
didn't think you should Castle right
away I thought you should when you play
this a six and c6 we should leave the
king in the center a little bit at least
that was what I thought well maybe we
should has different ideas but it was
the idea it's called the burn system and
the idea is to play b5 as you see that
g5 is well defended d4 after c5 we can
push white attacks on d4 white can deal
with so we say okay I'm gonna keep
things back in the center I'm just gonna
play b5 and put pressure and chip away
from the side this is writ named after a
Robert or
Donald Byrne remember which one but
players from the 1960s 1970s and this is
this is a pretty decent system and it
avoids a lot of the sharp lines where
they're very theoretical and this one is
right I felt like you should leave the
King in the center because maybe it's
playable tip it's a little risky so to
castle first okay so he that he castled
there should be three and now a six and
Knight to e2 white played and that was
the same thing that I didn't think that
White's should put the night there I
thought Bishop d3 because black is not
putting a lot of pressure on d4 so you
think you could get Bishop d3 and then
92 but he chose to go nighty to c6 so it
then there's this this move which is
anyone seen this before even know
anything about these this is the one of
the main ways of playing against this
Amish and then rook b8 and b5 that way
and this adds a little pressure to d4 c6
it doesn't create a target of the knight
on c6 and it also in some cases lets the
Queen out doesn't you know it because
more weight less chances to use this
open C file in the future but okay so c6
and what let's suppose white just
prevents b5 what does black do now what
do you think this is a move it well it's
not I don't think it's particularly good
but it's a move that a lot of people
might think about and say ok what black
wants to play b5 we'll stop them
so what's the problem with this move
yeah weekends before so what do you
think black might do though - yes c5 I'm
not sure about to c5 because first of
all okay white can probably take that
pawn maybe not know his black can often
sacrifice a pawn like that it's a
position we'll open up but let's say
white just goes d5 we've got the typical
position and a six and A four that helps
why I mean in all white it's usually
gonna play a four anyway if black plays
a six to stop d5 so this that's nothing
special for black and maybe a white can
take the pawn I don't know or even after
c5 white can leave the pawn on d4 and do
something else - maybe I would play d5
probably okay so it's not c5 really but
what else could like - Queen b6 so you
want to take b2 but first of all I think
it might lose the Queen like if Y just
goes here just let me check here here
where's the Queen go can only go to be
four right nowhere else now we go back
to 84 okay guarding c4 and attacking the
Queen again the only place to go is to
be 2 and no draw we don't agree to a
draw here because we play we play yeah
yeah Bishop c1 so blacks hoping for that
quick draw but no okay so so that's no
Queen b6 yeah you know Queen a5 is is a
reasonable kind of it looks like but
does the Queen real stay there yeah but
okay maybe I uh so you want to play b5
I'm not sure that's even the greatest
thing but if white but let's suppose I
go Roque 3 and now there's no B fire
right and eventually I try to I mean the
Queen is stuck there because I want to
play a 5 and lock down on the b6 square
so yeah you could do it but it's not
doesn't look like the best
yeah a five of course a five and now the
night can go at age six and we're not
necessarily gonna go right into B 4 but
then we're gonna go eat 5 and somehow
either take on d4 or make white play d5
you will have a c5 square forever
so this kind of locking down on the week
on the week square and blocking the
Queen side and now now white doesn't
have any mobility over there you know
they could say white goes here maybe go
here and then now now that night can
come to c5 and nope no b4 move ever or
he can play at night before a 97 night
c5 also something of course you have to
protect upon first but I don't think
that this is very good for a white so
most people don't go a 4 so ok so he he
went c5 actually and this this is the
same position I got as I think it's same
position I got against of all we've got
to the same position in a foreign few
more moves well okay so c5 so white
wants to lock down on b6 square but
black goes b5 and why you could take
this pawn of course right but actually
probably they take with the night
because it's not running away right this
develops the knight in the meantime a
beams at c4 but this is fine for black I
think this structure because you'll have
the B file and white center looks good
but black can counter-attack it and
there's nothing it's really doing blacks
pieces still have a lot of space after
the knight takes their there should be
six all that stuff so so white took on
d6 okay and black takes back and then
Knight f4 so he's letting out his bishop
and here Greece should Plato I think
that this was I don't know maybe his
preparation or maybe or maybe he just I
found it over the board but it's a rapid
game keep in mind I think it's like 20
minutes per side or something I don't
know with some is sort of 10 second
increment maybe 15 minutes I forgot but
it's 15 okay 15 minutes 10 second
increment that was a time control yeah
okay but anyway so so so this was a real
interesting move I played against cheb
all of just this move blending to c5 and
then here he Castle then I went to c5
and now the point is like if white goes
d5 I've got in this b5 move so I'm
pretty happy with that I'm gonna go here
here that type of thing you know
I got it just kidding in b5 is real
important so he he took I took back he
went here and then I went here so so he
got his Queen off the D file and I have
this Queen site majority but he has the
d5 square and a basically the game kind
of ended there's some sharp variations
and it was a draw you went here to
attack the pawn I went there traded
everything and didn't it got this move
in which is important because if I let
him blockade c4 and consolidate and
attack a6 and that type of thing I could
be in big trouble but this was important
I get three pawns against two over there
I had my majority and he's got those two
bishops he can't take this pawn because
because of Knight e5 and that's under a
pin and b3 of exposes this rook to the
bishop on g7 so you know yeah okay so so
he said he did this move and then I did
this was crucial point okay I'm not
gonna go so much into this game anyway B
395 he went here the the port important
point was that if he goes there I go
here to open c4 and then takes Knight c4
right okay he has to take it cuz if he
lets me take that Bishop and pawn on c3
then it's gonna be bad and then he has
this move shutting out my bishop but
then there's interesting I can take this
pawn and after this move will go here
and after that just take back and I've
lost exchange but I'm about to go rookie
too and I have to passed pawns there and
then this rook on d5 is gonna be stuck
because made on g2 and the pawns are
gonna start advancing so that was real
dangerous for white and here's something
else I could do here too
I mean I don't have to take a four right
away I can also play with c8 or
something I'm sure now exceeded well
whatever okay so he actually went Bishop
d4 and I went here now has to get off
the D file okay there was there was it
he decided to make a draw now cuz he
didn't see anything better there was
there was an f4 move in because there's
some crazy stuff after sorry not it for
Queen c3 c3 and then there was and then
some crazy stuff after 93 with blacks
down as well
no he's a little bit worse but okay he
decided to take here and then it takes
takes takes takes and it's the draw
because and I take here takes there
takes there takes there and now what do
you think blacks should do down upon
right so why would for four-time US
Champion I agree to a draw with me but
he saw what with Jenny what was gonna
happen so yeah what I do Brooksie one
it's important I mean okay if I don't
play rook c1 it's gonna be very hard to
draw but rook c1 it's totally drawn
because there's no way white can make
passed pawns entities its opposite
colored bishops right
there's no way white can make passed
pawns on both sides of the board I'm
gonna dress go a five I mean of course
if he goes a five I'll go Bishop d2 and
take the pawn and so with it four
against three there's absolutely no
chance with opposite colored bishops
zero chance I mean you know 1200 should
draw against the world champion without
unless he has Sykes him out or something
a5 you know and I just like you know he
can't make any pass pawn you need to
have two to passed pawns far enough
apart and there's no way for white to do
it so it's just no point in wasting time
so anyway that was that was that game
but anyway Greece should played a very
interesting Lou rook e8
so the idea what was shown in the game
Carl Carlson went Bishop e2 and now came
b4 chasing the knight first okay
whatever normally White's not afraid of
that because Knight is actually not so
bad on a4 in most cases and this pawn
could be hanging out
now comes that move so the point is this
pin on the e-file now white could have
stopped that by Queen to d2 then black
could play like I played and you saw
that sure ball went correctly Queen to
c2 not so I suppose black could just
played a similar way maybe had some
other idea I'm not sure but okay so you
went Bishop e2 here ninety-five and
whites white star I think you know
starts getting in trouble pretty soon
I'm not sure exactly where I didn't look
at it that carefully but so why can't
take this Knight right with a pawn
because black just takes here and the
bishop is in these positions when
there's a feeling chato Bishop like that
the bishop is so important the dark
squared bishop you trade off the white
one and blacks one has no opposite
number so that's you know that's very
tough away you can tell like well does
it look like okay position for white
here I mean yeah I mean if I didn't say
it or you guys wouldn't wouldn't want
the white side anyway it looks
complicated but once you realize that
white has no dark squared Bishop now
moves like Queen f6 are coming hitting
that night and pawn on d4 Queen a five
and then when this night starts coming
in to Queen h4 check in some cases and
you know certain real problems for white
okay so 95 also if white takes black
takes back and whites we get a position
where white center starts coming in to
her under a lot of pressure especially
he's not even castles yet so I think
white you know so anyway so so Carlsen
went there ship c1 okay now Knight to b6
and he decided to take that night which
is ends up liking a lot of pressure what
if the bishop just went back I mean
maybe black would just repeat positions
cuz Jawas black is okay I don't know if
he has anything to soup or other than
just repeating but you can play other
moves of course okay so he went white
took and then now d4 is under attack so
we had to go back to e3 but he keeps
having problems with this bishop so now
black goes d5 and again we wouldn't want
to play this movie
were possible but what is black - after
e5 yeah Bishop takes e5 and now it's
white it's busted right so dis hangs so
queen of d3 he played guarding efore and
III and now d take c4 f takes e4 and
here you know white still got that
impressive pawn center right but this
pawn center is just a weakness it's not
I don't think white white got a good
position from the opening here now we
should continue with a5 and Bishop a6 is
coming so maybe White's not to is
standing terrible but it's it's very I
would say it's uncomfortable I wouldn't
like to position for white listen you
know anyway rook d1 he guarded d4
because blacks about to chase the clean
away from that now Queen c2 and black
took and I took back because again Queen
takes rook e4 so there's so much white
is to go to these contortions to hold
his stuff alive now Knight to d7 White
has a slight moment he but black has to
catch up and develop and and why does a
slight moment to do something we okay
yes - castle right what can he what can
he really do and now Knight of 6 and now
suddenly again pressure on the e pawn
Knight to g3 not really anything I also
suppose that you 5 then Knight to g4
that's gonna be the same thing I suppose
so
so so tonight's G 3 Knight to g4
and again blacks gonna grab that Bishop
why can't keep the bishop so all this
has ended up white kept his pawn alive
in the Senate kept his pawns alive in
the center the blacks about to take the
bishop and then like White's gonna have
troubles it's gonna end his positions
gonna fall apart on the dark square so
Bishop f2 now you don't take the bishop
right because it's not running away so
that's important principle your your
Piatt your opponent's you want to trade
their piece but that piece is not gonna
run away so you don't take it right away
you keep the tension that's just almost
always the best principle unless there's
some specific thing that you you know
some specific reason in principle you
should keep the tension because your
opponent doesn't know you know this
bishop can't go away you can't go to you
won of course or anywhere else so black
doesn't take it right away which would
determine of course white white also
takes back with the Queen and now and
now f7 is under attack and black has a
spend a move defending that and then
it's not such a big advantage for block
anymore but rook a to d8 threatening to
take and then take on d4 so I think
White's had to play e5 there's nothing
else I guess right
okay II five and now now c5 so he
undermine the Pacific he undermined a
center and white took on c5 and now just
Queen c7 so now suddenly White's proud
center on e4 and d4 which she had from
the beginning of the game is now broken
up and this pawn on e5 is gonna fall and
still whites in trouble on dark squares
so okay he's still hanging on the rook
to d8 rook 5894 okay I don't know go
through ten look more closely to find
out where exactly white mistake maybe
was just the opening I don't know but
Bishop takes e5 threatening G and
threatening h2 so white has to go g3 and
now finally black took the dish
of course the white tried this would be
three then there's 93 okay so now he
finally took the bishop and here why
it's got a problem that if that's if the
knight takes then then Bishop d4 I
suppose and yeah probably there should
be four in whites and trouble there so
if Rick takes Bishop before definitely
and Queen takes not possible either same
thing so King takes you now Queen c6 and
rook e1 whites you know really this
Bishop is stronger than the night and
yeah I think I suppose that I mean I
mean blacks position is really promising
and it almost looks like he's just
winning and Grisha quince Bishop d4
check and after King f1f 5 now Knight f2
it's a slight difference in move water
couldn't black play fi right away and
now white loses the option because
Bishop d4 it's like we can always do
right so let's first find out where the
night's gonna go and now for instance if
the knight goes to g5 where if white
goes Queen c4 and a g5 Bishop to d4
Chuck and Weiss getting checkmated we're
at least losing a lot Knight he's just
before to check me well okay Bishop e3
but any case the King here go down here
you know go check here and then next
King has to come to one of these squares
and then Bishop takes b2 so that's it's
over
same with King g3 and so so f5 what is
white and has to go night to d2 and I'm
not sure now now black could go and take
the pawn on c5 oh sorry can't go night -
D - I mean he has to go night - D -
right away probably but then minimum
black can go and take the ponens Bishop
d4 and take on c5 and maybe have even
better check here and some sort of
you know yeah I didn't look too closely
as I'm about to try to figure it out
right now but in any case if five looked
right away it looks a better chance
better now
now black took the pawn but here White's
a little bit more coordinated and that
rooks and rook here and check check King
ran away bishop d4 I guess if Bishop e6
then now it's you know getting some some
play like this and also the rook can go
before so he had so he got a good idea
he he he let white take the pawn on a
five but now now he made a serious
mistake I see Queen b6 this let white
check on c4 and then get the rook to b5
which is a huge difference if you just
if black just plays King h8 I think
White's white I mean was white was
really busted after f5 I suppose but I
think White's pretty busted here to even
know blacks not up upon first of all the
white Kings in more danger the key black
king is totally safe on this diagonal
guarded by that bishop and the knight is
much worse and the rook
what kind of rook is almost trapped and
that was a big difference and somehow
the game turned after after Queen b6
although black was still okay but slowly
got outplayed like 93 now white got his
pieces into the center and he sort of
occupied the light squares in the center
and the pawn and now black you know he
kind of lashed out a little bit and
looked there okay now is now White's
pretty much out of out of the woods
minimum and white section I'm sure
Carlson was now ready to play for a win
already so before he was just busted and
now suddenly Queen is occupying an
incredible square in the middle of the
board the knight is also getting rid lek
has to constantly watch that this Knight
doesn't jump in pawn on before his weak
blacks just struggling to draw I'd say
maybe he can do it probably he can do it
but he needs to be accurate and
considering that it agrees should
definitely had a much better or you
could say winning position earlier that
King they're late he took this pawn and
now acts outside pass pawn therefore so
he needs to get some play you know quick
King King g2 so he he he White's King is
now safe guarded by the Queen the same
way blacks King would have been with a
bishop he had played King h8 or
something like that
so King g2 black went here and they came
back now he took he can't push to F 3 of
course White's guarding that clean
they're native to now the Knights gonna
move to even better square on e4 Black's
just trying to trade Queens ok black is
definitely gonna not lose if he trades
Queens because he'll stop the pawn with
a bishop the bishop is better than the
night and you'll take White's pawn on g3
somehow
okay so Queen there Bishop there Queen
checking out there there are some more
moves Queen be silent I don't know what
black was gonna do with King I don't
know I mean why it's not playing for I'm
sorry yeah I mean Queen sorry I'm
confusing myself of course Carlsen
playing for a win now 94 and now h5 so
his he wants to try to trade off White's
pawn he trades off the g3 pawn it's okay
but a5 and now I said H for he played
and white gets to connect protect or
black gets a protected passed pawn but
sits there's no way through this
position somehow for for black there's
no way to use that pawn the Queen and
Bishop just don't work together the same
way to Queen at night - you've heard
about this saying right Queen and Knight
work together well and this is a pretty
good example I mean this the Queen and
Bishop or just don't coordinate so well
and the Knights covering all the squares
and if black tries to go too far away to
do something then then White's gonna
quickly attack him with the Queen at
night you know his King is so so instead
I suppose it g4 with a plan of
eventually playing h4 somehow I suppose
this is a much better chance I don't
know
okay so h4g for Bishop III now you
checked in here the fatal mistake I
suppose black allowed the Queens to be
traded and here when the Queens are
traded with a pawn on g4 it's it's now
White's gonna win the bishop and keep
his pawn on g4 and win the game if if it
was still h5 and g3 black would be able
to you know play g4 advance the king and
then eventually h4 right and in the
minor piece ending that is while White's
Knight is heading over to the Queen side
to win the black Bishop like we'll just
trade off the g3 pawn and it'll be a
draw so but but in this position I don't
know probably low on time he he he
allowed Queen straight and he should
have on King h8 but I mean White's much
better here still I mean you probably
I'll show you exactly what you know he
probably gives some checks and pushed
the a pawn something like that I don't
know but whatever so he so he went King
g6 and white checked on d6 and now the
game ended quickly okay pawn push like
went here Knight they're about to win
the bishop pretty easy important to get
the King up here and not allow king of
four and black went there and then
traded and that's it black resigned
because I mean h3 is not going anywhere
and get back to guard the G pawn and
then bring the knight over so so I think
that this was a pretty interesting game
it shows like this system against the
Kings Indian I mean in the King's Indian
against his Amish and but then it shows
also you know good player I mean it was
looked like a winning position for black
I thought yeah I don't know but
especially in rapid can mix things up
and okay so that that was that game now
let me show you some that I don't know
what was since the average is around
1500 maybe I shouldn't have I thought it
was different but
I'll show you now some some some etudes
okay this way okay so you guys aren't
going to see the solution why each time
we put a movie
I don't know if I didn't know was gonna
do that okay so Bishop g7 okay but now
black can take this pawn and check no
and so this is just a draw you know so
that's that's not it but that's a start
so what else could we
huh Bishop f6 okay so let's let's try
this one
okay so black is going to definitely
take the ponen right now what
she's seven kit looks scary right I mean
Rick hae King f7 doesn't do anything
look g6
or g7 okay take King h8 only move rook
f7 okay only move is back yeah so that
doesn't achieve anything are you can
take the pawn on g6 but King King goes
up and now White's gonna how it's gonna
be king and rook against king and rook
chances of winning are probably pretty
low or any okay so Bishop f6 doesn't
quite do it and I don't see any other
you know you can take whatever you can
take g6 immediately you can withdraw so
what else
any other ideas yeah
very good okay so the but going back so
first of all we got the idea g7 right I
mean we hadn't got he found it right
away but g7 now the idea is okay but I
can't take the rook right there's white
Queens makes wins the game okay but the
black rook goes away and then white rook
has to go somewhere it doesn't matter
where black has a fortress this Bishop
is is here and it's a extra piece but
it's pretty useless stuck buried on h8
and there's nothing white can do I mean
he can't get his king anywhere black
just starts checking and chases it back
there's just no way through you know if
you realize that if you take this bishop
off the board then you have rotate shade
and then you realize like this position
is winning without that bishop so so
then so then then you have like you said
you check take the bishop check come
back and then g7 okay and now black rook
is under attack and of course if they
take the rook white makes a queen and it
takes the rook can mix a queen and if
this work goes anywhere
then rotate shape and skewers the king
and the rook wins so that was that was
interesting okay next one okay so this
is this is white to move yeah yeah
you've seen it before did you solve it
already okay yeah what's the move Bishop
f4 okay okay let's just we'll go that
Bishop f4 and now black is in zigs long
right so what is black - what can you do
okay Knight a fade and then was Bishop
d6 and then Knight goes let's say d6
okay let's suppose you promote and now
he takes it you know games over
that's us games over it's a draw oh you
win it against me let's see that's a
that's a fortress I mean you don't need
these pawns of course and it doesn't
matter that you have them either there's
you can't approach it out still meeting
him right so this is important that's
the first thing of this lesson because
you can actually get I mean this this is
crazy this is this problem I mean it's
gonna blow your mind but you're not
gonna get to any position like this or
ever have any kind of theme like this
ever happened in a game I promise you
but you can get this fortress so that's
you know so that's important to know
it's important knowledge oh it's also
without these pawns it's a fortress with
this you know let's suppose white goes
okay oops
oh it's Plex move sorry okay it's flex
we'll start throwing away the pawns who
don't care you know throw away some
pawns white doesn't take them it doesn't
make a difference because he's you know
and now now he goes there and here hoops
and why just never going to get through
because you know if there was another
file over here then black black could
but I could run away but here it's
stalemate so there's no way to get him
out of the corner so that's that's
that's the so it's not actually that's
not the solution but we're on we're
starting to learn some stuff this is a
weird position and when you it's gonna
take a while to figure out what exactly
is going on so Bishop before is a good
start but what about Bishop h6 it's
another I mean if you wanted to just
clean the pawn Bishop h6 would be the
most direct way right it's also draw
though what you got an idea uh-huh
Bishop f4 okay Knight fa8 okay Bishop d6
right King f2 okay now black is in zoogs
one right well it will be at least GF
for getting f3 f5 king of two
started asking you're gonna have to
throw the pawns away right so that's
that that would win right however black
has a special move here and yeah any
ideas what black could do and by the way
let's just go like Bishop h6 bishop oops
sorry Bishop h6 doesn't achieve anything
because King b8 and white start for
blacks gonna start bringing the King
over to take the pawn okay and obviously
if white doesn't get if white loses his
pawn it's a draw we know that and if he
comes here in white Queens and then goes
here tries to go back and white cuts
them off that's still a draw this is a
fortress also so the you know blacks
just gonna stay over here on c7 and d6
and c8 and if white tries to come closer
it's gonna be stalemate you know you
can't get through okay let's even
imagine black had some pawns there he
just start pushing them now until White
has to capture them anew so that's so
that even when the King's outside of the
corner it's also draw so Bishop f4 is
definitely the only way but do you see a
move for black yeah
Knight d8 yeah crazy move okay so what
can we do here
what happens if we queen yeah still me
right what happens if we look stalemate
and if we Bishop yeah we can take off
all of blacks pieces here the night and
the two pawns and we can even give white
about ten more bishops on that dark
square of course not on the light
squares we just need one light squared
bishop why we win but have a maybe maybe
ten fifteen however many we can fit on
the board and it's still a draw so
Bishop thing definitely doesn't help so
we have tonight because otherwise black
takes the pawn and that is definitely at
least a draw for blacks so so white has
to make a knight now suddenly black
realizes something real really weird
about the position what do you think
that is
huh what's that yeah we have a night of
course now let's say these are traded
there's the bishop and Knight are off
the board white wins there's no fortress
when there's a knight because the knight
will come in and you know yeah check him
and also can sacrifice on c6 that's the
main thing why I would do just take
bring the king up and sacrifice um c6
and win that way so no there's no
Fortress of white keeps the knight but
what does what does black realized
suddenly yeah yeah he realizes he
doesn't want to have his own night he
wishes his knight were gone you know
because that would be stalemate so now
he's gonna start a little chase like if
he doesn't do it why it's just gonna win
cuz as long as white keeps the knight
it's a win but he's going to start a
little chase where his knight tries to
get captured and whites Knight tries to
avoid capturing it yeah we can't we
can't take tonight cuz that stalemate
and if white goes to d7 then black can
take sorry black and just take on f4 and
and that's you know definitely blacks
the one playing for a win you know two
extra pawn okay it's probably draw but
whatever so night h7 also so yester
guard is he has to guard the bishop
right and black
he can't take on f4 because then then he
it's not stalemate and White's gonna win
when he was the night of bring the King
up capture the pawn sacrifice the knight
on c6 so so black says okay I mean Anna
same thing if he takes here it's gonna
take a little bit of technique to win
but White's eventually gonna win here
because there's no stalemate White's
gonna bring that I think it started with
bringing the King up and you know you
may even have to play Knight and Bishop
against King but you know it's it's a
win no so so so black what is black do
now what do you think yeah he's gonna
keep chasing tonight and again why can't
take the knight so what does why do
and it is night h4 yeah because if we go
somewhere else like this then black can
actually fork yeah but I can actually
fork the the two pieces and force weight
to capture the night and draw so it has
to go to h4 and what is black to in a g6
again if he tries doing something like
that okay no problem because as long as
this night stays alive White's gonna win
the game so he goes Knight g6 and again
why can't capture the night so what is
white - night you - okay and now you
probably guess what black does now right
mah for and now Knight e1 what is black
- Knight f3 check and that would force
the draw because if white takes it
stalemate in a feat trades that's what's
also Stanley but anyway it's fortress so
so what is black do after night night
there he's still trying to lose this
night isn't he huh oh sorry I mean if
white goes sorry white goes here though
instead right so what does black do now
Nagi - and now it looks like okay then
the bishops under tech and the Knights
under tech it looks like black has won
the battle and now he's going to force
wait to capture the night but what is y2
instead
yes 95 yeah and that protects the bishop
and black can't keep chasing because if
it goes here then this takes right and
this is no fortress right has two pawns
so they'll win and if black captures the
knight then now it's not stalemate
because he has that move so now White's
gonna win he's just gonna you know bring
the King over and capture the pawn for
instance and then come back and take
those pawns and eventually bring the
King up and then play see six like let's
say and just to show you Bishop take
okay goes say black goes there something
like that eventually of like it's gonna
be forced back and and then you know c6
and and then b7 and b8 say he doesn't
then then my course to take on b7 so I
hope you enjoyed that position
you